everything you did what you are you all
now where you belong
[Music]
they're coming
our enemy doesn't time
[Music]
doesn't stop
doesn't feel
hey everybody it's Charlie we got the
Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer and now
that we've had time to watch it a
billion times there's been a couple
really big questions that you guys had
on the previous video that I did so this
is gonna be all about the golden company
stuff during the trailer in the way
they're using them during season 8 a
little bit different from their book
story but a couple of really big Easter
eggs and foreshadowing for some book
story twists that they'll be adapting
albeit in slightly different versions so
we'll do a new round of the book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video so most of you know that the
golden company is one of the most famous
mercenary companies in the east they're
led by Harry Strickland currently as of
right now in the books this is him at
the front of the ship with the very
ornate looking golden armor looking down
at the rest of them with his back to us
with a very very shiny looking sword
that a lot of you also have a lot of
separate questions about which I'll
include in the video they have a rock
solid campaign record for all the people
that have had enough money to hire them
and their motto is our word is as good
as gold
even more notable that they've never
broken a contract since they were
founded quick history lesson they were
founded by bittersteel aka aegor rivers
one of the many infamous bastards of
King Aegon Targaryen the fourth the most
Robert Baratheon of all Targaryen Kings
Robert Baratheon interestingly enough
actually does have some Targaryen blood
in him through his mother's side of the
family but Aegon the fourth during his
time had many many bastards just like
Robert Baratheon did except the big
difference is he legitimized most of
them in causing a small scandal bequeath
the ancestral Targaryen Valyrian sword
black fire to his oldest bastard this is
the same Valyrian steel sword that was
wielded by Aegon the conquerer passing
the sword down to someone was basically
you telling them they would become the
next king the scandal was is that the
King already had legitimate heirs
through his Queen and obviously they
weren't having any of that once he was
legitimized though Damon took the name
black fire after the sword and that's
where you get the name Blackfyre
rebellion because it caused this big
civil war within the kingdom so half the
people's support of the black fires the
other have supported the legitimate heir
also really notable during this period
the three-eyed Raven on the TV show that
you guys have seen his real name is
Brendan River
he was also one of egg on the force many
bastards so he was fighting during this
period he fought for the crown for the
legitimate heir the black buyers lost
daemon Blackfyre the first the one who
was wielding the ancestral target and
Valyrian sword black fire he was killed
his heirs took that sword and fled to
the east were one of the other Targaryen
bastards bittersteel aegor rivers
founded the golden company so you have a
lot of Targaryen bastards in exiled
Westerosi Lords that lost their lands
and their titles because they were on
the losing side of the Blackfyre
rebellion fighting in what would
eventually become a very famous
mercenary company over time their
reputation grew as a mercenary company
because they were highly trained they
were trained as Knights and lures so
obviously they had much better skills
than your average mercenary group over
in the east eventually there were more
unsuccessful attempts at rebellion
against the throne there were obviously
other conflicts and then Robert's
rebellion there were people that fought
for the Mad King that were exiled and
lost their titles and lands more of
those people joined the golden company
so over time the golden company has come
to amass a lot of former Westerosi lords
and knights or people whose ancestors
lost their lands and titles and join the
golden company and they just grew up in
that lifestyle so Harry Strickland their
current leader the one in the trailer
that you're seeing here his grandfather
fought for the losing side during the
Blackfyre rebellion lost their lands and
titles so Harry Strickland grew up in
exile but a really big book character
Jon connington was exiled and lost his
lands and titles in Robert's rebellion
because he fought for the Mad King he
was one of Rey gars closest friends so
this is where we sort of get to the show
in the book combining a couple of
different golden company plots the
reason why the golden company in the
books is so important is because they're
currently leading another rebellion
quote-unquote to try and retake the
throne in a version of the Targaryen
restoration but a lot of you have asked
about the Aegon book plot so in the
books there's a member of the golden
company that is told that he's secretly
the son of Rhaegar Targaryen that was
spirited away during the sack of King's
Landing at the end of Robert's rebellion
remember the story about how the
mountain during the sack of King's
Landing on the orders of Tywin Lannister
killed Elia Martell and all of her
children one of those children with
Rhaegar was a baby boy named Aegon
Targaryen so there's a lot of stuff
happening in
day in the books and both on the TV show
now with the way that they're
positioning John Snow is the true born
heir of Rhaegar the most legitimate
choice for the throne in how Daenerys is
coming together with him so you're
already having sort of a Targaryen
restoration to the throne that it kind
of implies that this Aegon story line in
the books is fake he's a fake Aegon or
he's just a Blackfyre he's not really
the son of Rhaegar Targaryen they're
just telling him that so that all these
exiled Westeros sea Lords in the golden
company can get their lands and titles
back so we said that their motto is is
our word as good as gold they've never
broken their contract in the books they
break a contract that they have with the
city of Mir to defend them in an
upcoming war with the neighboring cities
of lists and Ty Roche up here so this is
big war happening they're being paid
enormous sums of money they offer them
slaves a giant harem for their leader
Harry Strickland you could have the
wealth of the world more money than you
could spend in your entire life and they
flat out break the contract to back this
fake version of Aegon in a bid to retake
the throne so that they can all get
their lands and titles reinstated so
think about it this way the TV show
obviously changing a lot of the book
plot there's probably not going to be a
fake version of Aegon because Jon Snow's
name is supposedly Aegon Targaryen that
might be different in the books but
because they've already named someone
Aegon on the show it's not like a second
one is gonna come running along but the
character motivations for what they do
in the books is still probably present
on the TV show where whether or not they
decide to do more book golden company
characters like Jon connington
you probably have a couple characters
from recent history that lost their
lands and titles because they fought for
the Mad King during Robert's rebellion
so Robert when he was named King exiled
them all like Jon connington that for
them the memory of the sting is still so
fresh like Jorah Mormont fled to exile
he was trying to regain favor by spying
on Daenerys for Robert Baratheon less
honorable means for trying to get his
lands and titles reinstated or at least
being allowed back in Westeros without
being killed on sight but the TV show
could use Jon Snow being outed publicly
as Aegon Targaryen true born son of
Rhaegar and legitimate heir to the
throne is one of the golden company's
reasons to break their contract with
Cersei with of course the stipulation
that Jon Snow and Daenerys reinstate all
their families lands and titles even if
it goes back all the way to the
Blackfyre rebellion
anybody who was exiled because they were
on the losing side of one of the wars is
allowed to come back we will give you
back everything that was taken from you
Cersei may also try to offer them a
similar deal which is why Jon Snow
secretly being Rhaegar son would be such
an important twist for their storyline
they would probably take either deal if
they don't have an emotional connection
with either side but you have this
Targaryen restoration you have people
like Jon connington even if he's not on
the show and they give that story to
harry strickland or one of the other
characters if he wound up being tv-show
rey gars best friend if you were to find
out that your closest friend had a
living heir and he was a potential
candidate for the throne and there was
somebody that you didn't care about like
Cersei wouldn't you turn and back them
knowing that they would also reinstate
all your family's lands and titles in
the trailer we see them arriving on
your--on ship harry strickland up in the
front there is possible one that the
show will do the ancestral Targaryen
Valyrian sword black bar which in the
books has currently been lost to the
ether people don't know what happened to
it it was in the possession of the
golden company in the surviving
Blackfyre heirs but in present day
nobody knows where the sword is so it's
always possible that it could resurface
at some later point the TV show because
they haven't done golden company yet and
there's been no mention of the sword
black fire I'm not expecting them to do
it but it's possible that Harry
Strickland here has that sword but
here's the thing if they are doing the
black fire sword most famous sword in
the history of Game of Thrones this
isn't it because it looks a little bit
curved the hilt is way different from
black buyers hilt there been a couple
different depictions between world of
Ice and Fire and a lot of the other
people that make art for the Game of
Thrones universe in an official capacity
this is the closest depiction that we
have of what it actually looks like so
the hilt would have to be very different
if they do it on the show it would have
to be some other difference or that
we're not seeing in any of these photos
to other big possibility that Jon Snow
and Daenerys forces are all but
obliterated in the big battle during
episode 3 at Winterfell so the odds are
a little more even when they come south
to King's Landing to deal with Cersei
and because the golden company is so
badass
even if Jon Snow Daenerys have greater
numbers they're not quite as effective
as the golden company fighters so it's a
smaller more even fight so I think the
golden company will be more important
later in the season also when you would
invoke a big twist telling them no no
no you're fighting ray gars trueborn err
this is Aegon Targaryen heir to the Iron
Throne last couple of episodes is where
you do all those big story twists where
the bells aren't quite as crazy but the
emotional turns are way way bigger in
the payoffs are way way bigger
so hopefully that explains a little bit
about the way the TV show is using the
golden company right now I don't think
they're gonna be doing a whole lot of
stuff the first half of the season like
I said but post all your theories in the
comments below there's still a lot of
really big questions in bonus videos you
guys have asked for based on the trailer
so I'll make those videos later this
week no worries congratulations to the
winner from my last big video Janine
Flores please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to watch the season 8
official trailer a billion more times
and click here for my playlist of Game
of Thrones season 8 teaser videos and
promos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight